bonjour bientôt c'est la rentrée
scolaire
aujourd'hui je vais au magasin acheter
du matériel pour la rentrée voilà
bonjour bonjour madame je voudrais
acheter des crayons je sais pas moi je
comprends pas du tout là bas dynapac des
crayons des crayons des crayons d'accord
décret et crayons pas de souci en a 100
magasins okay ensuite chose des pinceaux
pinceaux voilà sosa j'ai compris bravo
très bien pinceau une trousse pour
mesurer pour non non bon alors là je
comprends pas je suis désolé non
à ses trousses à winnie des trousses
d'accord une trousse pardon désolé
ok autre chose à une règle ça une gratte
un truc pour un inculte heures
non non non je suis désolé encore une
fois je le rends désolé mais non mais là
il n'y a pas pas là non non non il faut
aider la à des règles une règle voulait
une règle c'est ça le signe de règles
d'accord par bon ok pas de souci mais je
rajoute ça une règle autre chose un
conte pas d'accord un combat des compas
un compas voulait un compas d'accord
pour faire le tour pas de problème ça je
rajoute je m'adresse c'est bon c'est
fini c'est tout accord au revoir au
revoir au revoir bonjour
rentrée scolaire
magasin
crayon
pinceaux
truth
règle
compass
au revoir